maria has spotted the fresh tracks of a
snake in the sand
and it could still be hiding somewhere
in the tomb
john joins them to lend some support if
he's there
he's gonna be more scared of you than
you are viking woman
good luck okay if you're still in here
i come in peace
it's happening a bit maria don't tap
it just lift it yank it i don't want it
to end up falling on our mummy just be
safe
many of the snakes in egypt are deadly
you okay yeah there's tracks yeah don't
lift the stone
can we keep back from the door
well nothing
i do what i'm going to carry on with my
work and leave you with your snake
[Music]
maria and trisha can't be completely
sure the snake
has gone i removed a hole where
it entered okay you scared him off
anyway i think
but with the clock ticking they decide
they must press on
we have to be careful to distinguish
what is mummy and what is dirt here
yes this stone by excavating the body
from the mod
they hope to discover more about the
role of this person
in gabel el silcilla's community but the
state of the mummy
makes their task tougher more a little
piece of skull
yeah i got more hair burnt
they burn to such heat that
the white bones turn blue
ancient looters would often burn the
mummies they found inside a tomb
they're after gold and by burning the
mummies it's easier for them to open
them up
very sad the ancient egyptians would
have dreaded this kind of mutilation
they went to huge lengths to mummify and
protect their dead
believing that to succeed in the
afterlife key elements of the body and
soul
must be preserved intact
[Music]
the first was the ren your identity and
name
it lived for as long as your name was
spoken
was the heart the seat of your soul the
good force in your life
shayut was the shadow an image of
yourself that was reborn
every day at sunrise bar was a unique
personality
it left the body in the form of a bird
at night
and at death the car was the vital
essence
the force that animated the individual
and the cart was the physical form of
the body
which must be preserved or mummified for
the dead to be granted eternal life
i feel like i personally get attached
when i'm working on a mummy and you feel
like you're getting to know them
and you feel like a caretaker
[Music]
you